هذه هي السلالم التي صعدها يسوع ذات مرة
وفقًا للتقاليد الكاثوليكية
عندما نشأ لكي يحكم عليه
الحاكم الروماني بونتيوس بيلاطس قبل
صلبه في سماء مثل جيسو
سليم ، يروي إنجيل يوحنا أن يسوع
صعد هذه السلالم عدة مرات
كوندينادو مارتي  يقول عميد السلالم المقدسة ،
الأب فرانشيسكو غويرا ، إنه
تم إحضارهم إلى روما من القدس في
القرن الرابع للمرة الأولى منذ
قرون ، ويمكن لزوار روما صعود
الدرج الأصلي البالغ عددهم 28 درجة بفضل عملية
الترميم الأخيرة التي أزلت الألواح الخشبية
التي كانت تغطي السلالم.  على مدى 300
عام ، ظهر
اكتشاف مفاجئ لأخاديد عميقة في الرخام
ناتجة عن قرون من البلى
من ركب وأقدام الحجاج
وقطرات دم يسوع التي قيل
إنها سقطت على درجات تميزت
بصلبان القرون الوسطى في ثلاثة أماكن
يشرح فرانك شيرا ، جندي أمريكي متمركز في ألمانيا ، صعد الدرج مع أطفاله الستة ، ما الذي
يعنيه الفعل التعبدي بالنسبة له.  حان الوقت
للتفكير به في التفكير في الأشخاص الذين
كان لهم تأثير على صالح عائلتي
وأولئك الذين أعرفهم في
الجنة أو الذين يحاولون الوصول إلى
هناك وفرصة للصلاة من أجلهم
روى الآخرون قصصًا عن
التحولات والتجارب العاطفية العميقة
من صعودهم إلى
أعلى الدرج هي غرفة تسمى
قدس الأقداس كانت ذات يوم كنيسة خاصة
للباباوات وتحتوي على رفات
القديسين وواحدة من أقدم أيقونات
يسوع الموجودة في روما من الخامس
قرن من الزمان ، سيتم قريبًا تغطية الدرج
مرة أخرى بالخشب لحماية الرخام
ولكن في الأسابيع القليلة المقبلة
يمكن لزوار روما المشي أو الركوع على الأقل
في ما يُعتقد أنه الخطوات الأصلية
ليسوع